AND TELL IT ALL."
THE ONE PERSON I COULD DO THAT
WOULD BE JOHN KELLY.
>> Bret: JOHN, THANK YOU, AS
ALWAYS.
SOME OF THE NATION'S TOP
INTELLIGENCE OFFICIALS WERE
FORCED TO DEFEND THEIR AGENCIES
TODAY DURING THE CONGRESSIONAL
TESTIMONY WE JUST REFERENCED.
IT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE A DAY FOR
THE WORLDWIDE THREAT ASSESSMENT,
BUT CHIEF INTELLIGENCE
CORRESPONDENT CATHERINE HERRIDGE
REPORTS THERE ARE ALMOST AS MANY
REPORTS OF THREATS FROM WITHIN
AS FROM THE OUTSIDE.
SPEAK UP MANY, MANY, MANY TIMES
A DAY I AM CONFRONTED WITH
UNBELIEVABLE EXAMPLES OF
INTEGRITY AND PROFESSIONALISM
AND GREAT.
>> A FORCEFUL DEFENSE FROM
CHRISTOPHER WRAY, WHO WAS ASKED
ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
CHARACTERIZATION OF WRAY'S HERO.
>> DO YOU THINK THE FBI'S
REPUTATION IS IN TATTERS AND ARE
YOU CONFIDENT?
>> I AM A BIG BELIEVER IN THE
IDEA THAT THE FBI SPEAKS THROUGH
ITS WORK, THROUGH ITS CASES,
THROUGH THE VICTIMS IT PROTECTS.
>> THE HEARING, OFTEN DOMINATED
BY TERRORISM, GOT INTO THE BRUSH
INVESTIGATION THE POLITICAL
FILES.
ON THE HOUSE REPUBLICAN STAFF
MEMO THAT ALLEGES SURVEILLANCE
ABUSES BY THE AFGHAN
SURVEILLANCE APARTMENT DURING
THE 2016
ELECTION.
>> WE HAVE DONE AND CONTINUE TO
HAVE NO GRAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
ACCURACY OF THE MEMORANDUM
BECAUSE OF -- WE PROVIDED
THOUSANDS OF DOCUMENTS THAT WERE
VERY SENSITIVE AND LOTS AND LOTS
OF BRIEFINGS, AND IT IS VERY
HARD FOR ANYBODY TO DISTILL THAT
DOWN TO 3.5 PAGES.
>> BUT THERE WERE NO HARD
QUESTIONS FOR THE PANEL ON THE
DEMOCRATS COUNTER MEMO THAT
NEEDED HEAVY REDUCTIONS BEFORE
THE PRESIDENT SAYS IT WILL BE
DECLASSIFIED.
ON THE 2016 INTERFERENCE, THEY
SAID THERE WAS UNIVERSAL
AGREEMENT.
>> THERE SHOULD BE NO DOUBT THAT
ARE THAT ITS PAST EFFORTS AS
SUCCESSFUL AND HE IS THE 2018
U.S. MIDTERM ELECTION AS A
POTENTIAL TARGET FOR RUSSIAN
INFLUENCE OPERATIONS.
>> WILL RUSSIAN
PRESIDENT VLADIMIR PUTIN'S
GOVERNMENT IS DISRUPTING THE
MIDTERMS, WRAY SAID THEY ARE
ALREADY WORKING WITH: SECURITY.
>> DHS RECENTLY SCHEDULED
MEETINGS -- THERE ARE WAYS THAT
PEOPLE ARE LITTLE BIT CREATIVE
AND FORWARD-LEANING TO EDUCATE
THE STATE ELECTION.
>> THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE SMART
PEOPLE.
THEY REALIZE
THEY REALIZE THAT THERE ARE
PEOPLE ATTEMPTING TO MANIPULATE
THEM, BOTH DOMESTICALLY AND
FOREIGN.
>> ONE SENATOR CALLED FOR
GREATER INVOLVEMENT FROM THE
TOP.
>> I JUST WISH YOU ALL COULD
PERSUADE THE PRESIDENT, AS A
MATTER OF NATIONAL SECURITY, TO
SEPARATE THESE TWO ISSUES.
THE COLLUSION ISSUE IS OVER HERE
UNRESOLVED.
WE CANNOT CONFRONT THIS THREAT,
WHICH IS A
WHOLE GOVERNMENT RESPONSE WHEN
THE LEADER OF THE GOVERNMENT
CONTINUES TO DENY THAT IT
EXISTS.
>> DURING THE 3.5 HOUR SESSION,
OTHER HEADLINES UNFOLDED ON
NORTH KOREA.
>> KIM JONG UN IS NOT HEARING
THE FULL STORY.
THAT IS THAT THOSE AROUND HIM
AREN'T PROVIDING NUANCED, .
>> ON CHINA.
>> I'M NOT SURE IN THE HISTORY
OF THIS NATION WE HAVE EVER
FACED A COMPETITOR AND POTENTIAL
ADVERSARY OF THIS SCALE, SCOPE,
AND CAPACITY.
>> ON THE NATIONAL DEBT, THE
NATION'S INTELLIGENCE TO CHIEF
TESTIFIED IS UNSUSTAINABLE AND
POSES AS A NATIONAL SECURITY